and you think you have a lot of clocks
to change this weekend so right now i
have about 20 clocks so i have to do
them all mag nasser has been in the
clock repair business for six decades
well the best part of the business is
when you do the service you get paid
right away
and that is the best part of the
business born in egypt trained by his
father in new york and applying his
craft here in town the past 20 years
his business is clock craft he knows his
stuff you will see that clock is 150
years old and the movement was
completely worn out so i installed a
brand new movement so does he dread
daylight saving time quite the contrary
well it's a very very good because it
boosts our business and it will shows it
will show us that we care about our
customer when they call you we will help
them over the telephone how to set the
clock
his expertise ready to be dispensed stop
the clock for an hour
so so you don't have to go 11 hours to
rotate the hands
every 15 minutes you advance the hand 15
minutes at a time let the clock chime
daylight saving time also gives mag a
chance to reconnect with customers they
help us and help our customer now if you
don't then the people don't call you at
least they keep in touch with you
minimum of twice a year
i have a lot of customers that they call
me and they get confused so i held them
over the telephone and i will tell them
what to do i give them step-by-step
instructions so this is like mid april
for the tax guy correct exactly daylight
saving time is your tax time correct mag
will be busy on what is a big business
weekend in his home shop with advice
instruction and an opportunity to
reconnect